au nom de toute l'équipe sachez
qu'aujourd'hui c'est l'anniversaire
d'agathe
[Applaudissements]
sa mort
aussi longtemps que vous avec les
sionistes plus les faits souvent nu
absolument
il fait des shows nous a dit qu'il
savait ça d'ailleurs déjà fait une fois
quoi comment vous savez ça vous avez
déjà fait une chenille non ça c'était
les goûts mais pas avec moi vous êtes
table quoi quel rapport vous voyez
vraiment l'homme et moi danser
[Musique]
tout nu dans une maison abandonnée
c'est que chez nous la fait avec vous je
vais y arriver je les fais chez vous
dans votre appart on a fait chez vous
oui mais vous avez fait une cheminée
d'un grand couloir tata boscolo du
propriétaire quoi c'est parce que dorman
pouvait parler mais ça rigolait quoi
johnny walt oui enfin n'étaient pas très
nombreux et t8 mais c'est rigolo et eva
joly se transforme en brochettes agathe
28 ans agathe 28 ans tue toujours la
plus jeune normalement oui oui pour
l'instant vous êtes la plus jeune oui
bah c'est normal les autotours mai et
j'ai appris un scoop énorme deviner
l'âge de jimmy mohamed 5 et non 32 32 ha
ouais mais c'est bien qu'il a 55 ans les
médecins c'est ça les médecins oui mais
c'est les mercière de daga filles
apprennent paul qui me demande quel est
son statut est ce que les célibataires
ou pas alors c'est une question ça
j'écoute
j'étais avant d un truc de célibataire
ou pas alors c'est moi c'est pas moi de
répondre moi je réponds pas pour les
autres fois qu'ils me demandent mes des
potes des photos comme ça dépend quelle
perte de temps et ce à n'importe quel
poste des bonheurs automobilistes belges
a response varie selon les cantons coeur
est à prendre ou pas non mon coeur est
pris sur moi quand on a quelqu'un dans
le coeur et dans la tête ça veut pas
forcément dire qu'on est en couple mais
on pense à quelqu'un quoi sa femme et
lui 1800 av je pense à vous il est il
proche
oui te connais pas onu
[Applaudissements]
le gars en fait il est là mais elle en
fait lauda yalouz
c'est quoi le bouquet la personne quoi
tu ailles et 38 en tout cas franchement
une bonne question de jambi on va on va
avancer on va trouver là dessus un kéké
tiens je vais m et je vous dire qui je
vais mettre sur l'anc est géré est notre
meilleur enquêteur notre meilleur
enquêteur et accélère on est sûr que
dans son jeu mais maître jean-michel ce
qui vous permet de dire ça jean-michel
oui vous avez prises et le montant
modère quand je voulais savoir un truc
généralement j'arrive à le savoir
oui je sais que quatre ans près de sa
soirée quand ça sent dans les infos sur
le portable